but now this album in general cuz you're
listen man if y'all don't follow glasses
on Twitter he's one of the most
frustrating entertaining follows ever
there are very few things that I I so me
and you it's funny because I'm getting
ready to redo the whole set and a lot of
my set is going to be dedicated I bought
a doggy style on vinyl the OG vinyl good
that's good and I bought the uh o OG
cassette I've have had three copies of
the C I was a kid that's a good one but
you and I are very aligned with some
hip-hop opinions some very very some and
four out of 10 most of most of the ones
that we're very passionately dug in on
have to do with Snoop and have to do
with doggy style because doggy style is
the most important hip-hop album in my
entire life sure and it's the most it's
the greatest one of all the hip-hop and
I I kind of have like a three album
where I could be like this this is my
goat album right it's elmatic it's Doggy
Styles probably get Richard die trying
it in any order that those could be one
two or three on sure Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday whatever but doggy s
was the most important in my life that's
fair and in my opinion Snoop Dog somehow
while being the most famous rapper in
the world by far still underrated he's
underrated yes agree how is this a
possibility by the way my bucket list
interview I hit his guy Kev once a month
and I'm like dude I'll go to the it's my
bucket list alltime interview I can
interview Snoop I might cry cuz I want
to explain to him me getting doggy style
on accident changed the path of my life
but how is Snoop still
underrated how does that happen well
he's the greatest hip-hop artist of all
time right but if you favor certain
Styles maybe Snoop won't fit that style
so immediately he's from the West so
that's going to immediately take credit
from the the Cornerstone of hip-hop in
New York or the East Coast that's going
to be a corner Stone issue that he's not
from the right East he's from the West
um his style is like a
oneoff you know I mean to me is like a
descendant of like short and LL cooj
super smooth you know I mean but you can
see he's such a hip-hop kid like First
videos you can see the special ed in his
movements how he moved and how smooth he
was um I think the majority of it
is one he's from the west coast and not
from the East two would probably
be he's
alive he's alive that's real real [__]
you know what I mean he's alive and
that's really important which is even
greater because you look at him now and
he's probably like
still the most
recognizable you know rapper on the
planet no I I do say that I say there's
certain artist that if God forbid they
passed away would shoot to the greatest
of all and I I really think think that
about Kendrick like I tell people like
oh yeah we we really kind of don't
appreciate Kendrick like we should cuz
if he passed away tomorrow for whatever
reason he's the goat um he's at least
he's at least like solidified in that
conversation in the same way we talk
about P it's really dope and I try not
to comment on dot because you know dot
is my friend and somebody I I love to
death you guys have done records
together way way deeper you know I mean
it's [__] really my partner but it's
like he's also a generation undermines
so I have to listen to to a lot of
younger people tell me versus me giving
my cuz I I have [__] that I'm looking
like you know Scarface I'm say scarf
it's like as much as I love DOD is like
Scarface you know mean he raised me do
is like well I would just say cuz like
we put biggie in certain conversations
based on two albums when he was alive we
got two albums from that's them them
albums is [__] that well no those albums
are incredible but what I'm saying is if
you if if you look at just like if
something happened to died it it'd be
frantic it'd be frantic it it it would
probably re it would probably reshape
hip hop at that point permanently I
think unfortunately people sometimes
when they
leave uh prematurely they get
appreciated more and I think we've seen
that happen a lot of time and time again
over the last decade or or or or their
Spirit can be free to roam about the
cabin yeah cuz I think a lot of times we
don't get into like even with nip right
I always felt like people look at gang
bangers and feel like I can't relate
right even though like you know [__]
is regular human beings but they can't
relate and I think it became so
important for people to to get what he
was on when he passed away cuz it made
him mortal right people really look at
gang banging like like a he-man sport
like oh man if they die I don't care or
you know or they can't die or they did
something to die or they in prison you
know versus some dude just really
running a business and having a problem
and somebody taking his life and I think
there's nothing more human than that so
I think that's what happened well back
to the Snoop thing I think what happened
with Snoop was when we look at things
through like um a biased
hip-hop you know I guess goggle cuz for
whatever reason a lot of The Taste
makers in hip-hop over the years have
been very East Coast biased I mean they
yeah from New York I think if you think
of like doggy
style I think snoop's early on
contractual [__] got in the way of him
probably being looked at in the same way
we look at Nas or I would even say Nas
because Nas had some issues with his
discography but let's say Jay-Z right
because dog I think dogf father was an
album I
enjoyed um but it wasn't doggy style and
then there was the kind of the
disconnection with death row and then he
went to No Limit and then the then that
first No Limit album was forgettable no
limit top dog was my [__] I love that I
love the last meal the last meal was my
[__] but I think like it's it's almost
like we kind of lost some years of peak
Snoop in the way that we Pro cuz
obviously the Dr Dre relationship
dissolves so that that mattered a lot
you know what I mean and then he has
this other run in the middle of his with
career with forel the blue carpet
treatment Rhythm and gangster Rec we oh
my God that we just like forget about
yeah even that whole album he did with
forel um was it called Bush yeah yeah
was dope as [__] so I just think that
like man for whatever reason like we
really didn't get to really
enjoy like Peak Snoop Dog in the way
that we should have because of things
that were probably outside of his
control because there was the murder the
murder trial so so let's so let's
actually let's actually clear frame like
let's not talk about what we reading on
Wikipedia let's go by what really
happened right in 1992 we got the first
Snoop Dog album no disrespect to Dr Dre
The Chronic that's the first first Snoop
Dog album fair enough shout out to Dre
Big Brother snoops coming out party he's
on 14 of the 15 records he wrote pretty
much the record right that's the first
Snoop out the crime then doggy sty
dropes that's 94 right that's 93 93 okay
then doggy style is such a big deal it
sells 870,000 albums in the first week
890,000 the second week right which 50
came and did again right that
happens it's so impactful if forces a
change on the whole game it turned like
people get mad when I say this but Tupac
had to become more of a gangster rapper
because of this album yeah that's why
you go get thug life because of dog pan
you go get some 40 Crips yeah right you
ice cube has to become more of a
songwriter he was already a a decent
song rer but he was a [__] masterful
pin MC but then he has to kind of
structure style to make more records cuz
dog is destroying destroying everybody
everything on the radio right boom so
like he shifts the game like he totally
which is what a classic is it shifts the
game right and you just
boom then it's such an impactful album
one song spawns a whole another album in
94 murder was Mur was the case yeah
that's so much the [__] sells triple
platinum mhm right so that's 92 The
Chronic right which is a snoop album 93
which is doggy sty which is obviously
snoop's debut 94 which is murder was a
case that's off of Snoop album 95 his
group comes out yeah he's on seven to
eight of those records right dog fol
yeah dog classic
album right I think I think it's a
classic album it's for sure a West Coast
Classic I think it's a classic album I'm
not I wouldn't even I'm not going to
debate that but we're going to get to
some debates about yes we are but so we
got [__] 92 93 94 95 Dre's leaving so
Dre leaves so DJ poo steps in and
finishes attempts to finish
Dog Father in 96 so what happened is we
actually did get to enjoy Snoop we got
so Snoop carried death row for sure but
on his back yeah you know what I mean
and then Pac came and that's why I
always get upset at that argument Pac
was jealous Snoop was jealous of Pac Man
this [__] been carrying the world's
greatest most impactful record label
cash money is probably Hip Hops gra
label but yeah he was carrying the most
impactful label at that time you know I
mean of all time as far as impact imp
yeah right because it's this is the
birth of gangster rap at the highest
yeah and then the tree I always say PE
like if you look at the Dr Dre tree look
at the Snoop tree look at the shg Knight
tree everything came right so right so
he carries it on his back and then
finally Snoop right so poac comes home
and then boom now you got another star
it's like the Warriors and Kevin Durant
right you get another star you you get
this guy from the Thunder Booker and
Kevin Durant you know what I mean like
not like that it's like from the
Thundering to the
Warriors
Curry so then he comes over and now you
like oh I ain't got to do all the work
right and then Pac comes and y'all give
him all the records y'all help y'all
give him the best beat and he puts up he
puts up them [__] go out there and finals
MVP put up 50 easy work but Snoop Steph
Curry but yeah right and he's just like
do your thing yeah and then he still has
to put out another album in '96 so we
get albums from Snoop in '92 93 94 95
and dog father in '96 so when Dre is
leaving Pac dies says Fran is madness
still a snoop album is needed to you
know carry the banner because you got
mavelli at this point so those three
records all lies on me mavelli and
dogfather dogfather produced by DJ Pooh
does most of the heavy lifting they
don't really get a chance to finish it
cuz we got to get this album out Pac
pass we got to get
we always got enough a snoop it's
literally just it's like survivors like
it's survivors guilt like he lives a
survivor's lifestyle where he survived
the craziest [__] and he's right here so
we don't really appreciate him yeah I
think we just I think when we think of
like Snoop albums we think
of he doesn't get credit for the chronic
obviously but if you think about it the
song the main song from The Chronic that
we celebrate who's on the song Snoop and
that's how it's been the whole time I
don't disagree even a dog fol what's the
main
song Snoop son onic yeah New York New
York yeah great great video caused a lot
of man just carrying all the weight man
so I would just say I would just say
like I just think that like
unfortunately and and and this is kind
of like a very convenient way to look at
things it's like damn the what if of
like if they would have kept somehow
kept that nucleus together together for
like another two or three years you know
what I'm saying like something I'm going
say man it was born out of trauma like
Dev R was born out of trauma it was born
out of a situation with e you know I
mean that probably wasn't a real enough
situation for it to to for them to break
up but it it it was born out of like
know like all Street Urban culture you
know what I mean so we got what we got
so we just got to be grateful we got
that four years of incredibleness and a
lot more after that yeah cuz we did get
the dz's album that was pretty cool
great album shout out to Daz man also
one of the greatest never I'm mad we
never got the corrupt produced Dr Dre
album True the excuse me the Dr Dre
produced corrupt doing the be been crazy
imagine that drops in even then what's
crazy about corrupt is like somehow like
I think streets is a mother is like I
mean one of the most underrated Fred
[__] Fred is [__] F Fred re
fantastic oh that [__] album is so
hard ups and down like the [__] Fred
does crazy Fred is just nasty and he he
really don't get enough credit but
sonically I had to call him probably
about 5 months I was like d you like
really C I don't know how are you doing
that but even his Sonic separate
completely different so I think Snoop is
just disrespected because he's from the
West until he survived and I think um
his level of celebrity got to a place
where most people stopped looking at him
as a rapper and almost started looking
at him more as like a cultural figure
and and like just an Entertainer like
which is why I say he's the greatest
hip-hop artist because when you
understand hip-hop is Street Urban
culture there is no greater
representation of culture than Snoop Dog
yeah like Snoop is like this nigga's a
[__] that was [__] walking on he's well
I mean he's done things that no artist
like no rapper has ever done and will
never do 30 not not a hip-hop artist
maybe like a drake somebody who's not of
the culture no no he's not okay we not
going to do that he's not of the street
Urban culture you can't listen to music
he so is Eminem Not A hip-hop artist
he's from Detroit okay he from the
ghetto okay okay Drake is a from a
middle class Canadian neighborhood so if
someone comes from a middle class family
they notop no so you have so you're
telling me in your eyes you have to be
from a street urban community yes in
order to be considered Hip-Hop Hip-Hop
is the first genre of music forgive me
because I know everybody better listen
to P like go you can't kick me it's not
the point I'm saying hip hop is Street
Urban artistic expression so
didn't well I mean we could probably
really nitpick this this discussion and
then I'm going kind of Po yeah I'm going
kind of Drake's been popped saying Drake
is kind of popped that's a different
statement somebody in my top five okay
somebody in my top five I've had that
and I'm glad you said Kanye West did not
grow up in the hood and I've been
thinking this whole time he his mother
was a teacher and I've been thinking
this whole time I was like is he really
cuz I think as much as he's in my top
five and I appreciate him I think he is
the problem do you think Diddy is hip
hop Puff Daddy oh puff is an executive
so you don't think Puff Daddy is hip-hop
no I think puff put out hip-hop X but he
is hip-hop I don't know if he's
responsible for so much history Jimmy
a yeah but did he's did he's produce
records yeah really yeah has he really
in the same way Quincy Jones has
produced records yes
he puts the right people together the
right forgive me forgive me Diddy puff
my bad look I don't know but Kanye has
been my my greatest dilemma but if you
think about it right this is going to
sound crazy so Kanye is in my top five
cuz I love you know I think the world of
Kanye there were times I I've expressed
to charlot man I think Kanye is a
prophet for living so I think this much
of him but if you think about his first
single like he got into a car crash
great record like all American car crash
with Insurance yeah but what's wrong
with that that's nothing it's like
Madonna could have made that song that's
not true yes it's a middle class song
about a man get into a ction than with
insurance so you're saying there there
can't be middle class raps yes Drake is
a fantastic rapper fantastic nonstop is
my [__] but that don't mean they are hip
hop Street Urban culture now a lot of
people disagree with me some people like
long as you practice what them [__] do
then you're one of those [__] but you
know how I feel about that but my point
is with Kanye right out like half a
hip-hop fast get that then you say you
aren't hip-hop fast because I'm going
tell you why because look what happened
to rock and roll mhm it ain't a [__] in
sight look what happened to
Jazz cuz soon as you start letting
everybody in the door guess who getting
kicked out first I don't think that's
ever going to happen in hipop guaranteed
they've tried it's h it's only been it's
only been 50 years they they've been
putting out records for 40 it's
guaranteed to happen I'm not sure sure
there's uh you know what's funny is I've
always thought to myself like who's the
white you know like who's the white
that's like the white of whites and Hip
Hop that like can actually make this
thing work like and like sustainable
long time let's get rid of Eminem cuz
Eminem is an alien yeah he's like a
anomaly in the world 30 40 years ago
Eminem would have been a punk rock it's
Eminem by the way right if you were to
say it it's Eminem but but we had this
conversation hip hop and punk rock are
brothers Step Brothers right
right uh uh um same father oppression
and poverty different mothers the area
the Earth so you so CU because this is
there's a lot of artists who have
families that went to college that had
middle class jobs a lot people from
together that went to college no at
middle class middle class areas little
yachty yeah but would you really do you
look at little yachty and be like oh
that's a hip-hop guy yeah no you just
only feel like that cuz he raps no I
think he I think he's hi hop for sure
yeah but I'm saying because he raps if
he was and I also think he's also
contributed a lot to culture he's he
wrote city girls act up he kind of
kicked off lowkey this whole [__] yeah
but so did Jimmy IV so it's a lot of
other people but not in the same way
jimy I what song did Jimmy I right but
don't that's not again you're you're me
there's people outside of the culture
who have wrote cultured songs okay let
me ask you a
question you're so cuz cuz I feel that
there has been and I'm not saying I know
of little yach's hip hop I don't know
little yach there has been an uptick in
completely in what it's a complete
takeover of middle class people ever
since the blog era happened yes soon as
college kids started dictating what was
cool within Street Urban culture you
seen the change because it became the
guys that they could deal with yeah but
to me that's still hip-hop that's not
that's just music hip hop is the culture
like if you don't talk like us if you
don't talk like us how and there's the
five elements of Hip Hop no no no those
are expressions how you express the
culture so I just think that like if you
look at a guy I'm trying to think of a
guy you said the blog ER so I'm just
trying to think Kanye is the greatest
conversation and as one of my favorite
guys and as one of your favorite guys
yeah and kany is probably the most
influential artist of the last I don't
know 30 years who did he
Influence
People Travis Scott is hip-hop middle
class people I don't even think Travis
Scott considers himself hip-hop that's
not true I don't I don't think so did
you listen to the drums on the new album
um again drums are not exclusive to
hip-hop I know but just you know they've
been having hard drums in house and a
lot of other stuff that hip-hop birth
okay so outside of but I'm not again I
haven't studied all of those guys to say
their [__] specifically I've been saying
this about Kanye and I think that's why
I mean Kanye did influence a sound that
kind of I mean him and just blae
fingerprints all over the blueprint it's
really blink though it's who Bank well
Bank started it everybody started
following [__] okay so if you listen to
the blueprint right yeah and then after
the blueprint everyone started sampling
but it's all based off [__]
okay this is it's important to know this
truth and and they all I think that's an
opinion though no this is a fact I don't
think you can say that like just blaze
and Kanye weren't chopping up samples
before [__] they wasn't doing it the way
they were doing it on a blueprint before
[__] that style that's that sound that
was birthed out of that is [__] well the
credit goes to
[__] I'm saying the general public would
credit the blueprint as the album that
kicked off a sonic wave of like people
sampling sure like high pitch samples
again again I'm with you I'm all in I'm
just saying there's a fact and then
there's a ignorance okay so are you
telling me Kanye is not hip-hop I'm
telling you that's that's been my
dilemma right because cuz he is hip-hop
well this is the problem right he's
Kanye West but that doesn't mean
anything it does first off nobody in
[__] hip hop put Marilyn Maro up on
their [__] wall as a kid what do
what's I don't understand the
correlation between Kanye and Marilyn
Monroe cuz he talked about putting up a
poster cuz of Marilyn Monroe on his wall
what's wrong with that why the [__]
would a [__] from where we from put up
Marilyn Maron they W cuz they think
she's hot no none of us think she's hot
that you're speaking for a lot of people
from the ghetto I speak for all of us
I'm sure a lot of people in the ghetto
would clap her cheek none of yes we
would anybody's but we wouldn't think
she's hot it's too many hot [__]
sisters from that time he Compares Kim
Kardashian to her like yeah but Kim K is
is lovely you you don't you don't no
she's not you don't think Kim K is
lovely no she was okay she was a regular
you think she was okay yeah she was a
regular they used to had him in Glendale
by the by the
barrel there was Kim Kardashians by the
barrel by the Barrel in Glendale that's
that's the normal fine girl in Glendale
When you go to the scenes I'm in
Glendale a lot yeah I live in in Burbank
don't have the plastic well I just don't
see I've seen I don't see by the barrel
I see them by the Barr shout out to the
beautiful Armenian women who are in GL
they're great they're fine and they Kim
kard yes they are they Kim Kardashian
fine all of original Kim Kardashian not
this version I don't know what's going
on I'm not saying that there aren't some
Kim Kardashian fine Armen I'm just
saying that I think that you're uh
you're overstating your point of no no
no I'm telling you the truth listen if
you think about it right listen to every
other thing you loved about hip-hop
growing up right the struggle the the
the the ideas even how they party I
liked hey you know what I liked what
first of all I love doggy style sure and
the other album that really I like the
kind of like the
horror demonic Mystique of Bone Thugs
and
Harmony the IGI are you
with it was the melody that did it for
you
though Ouigi and you know what else I
liked what they had the best Harmony
since Beach Boys probably
fantastic harm I mean I can tell you
like from creeping on a come up to East
1999 Art of War man God bones again
somehow criminally underrated super uh I
also really enjoyed Brother Lynch Hung
Lynch is dope I got that [__] for about
four zones I had to get dirty on brother
Lynch had I always give props of his
album season of The Sickness it was a
very uh dark album where he talked about
eating children I like Lynch yeah bu
Lynch Lynch is a nut but the point I'm
saying back to yay right so brother
Lynch hip
hop uh I would imagine so he's from like
a really [__] up getet on sack but him
talking about eating children but I
think he also created would not be the
something that a normal dude from the
hood would talk about well it's not I
mean he's like he's like um Edgar Allen
po also also Bone Thugs in harmony
talking about playing around with a
Ouija board and talking to uh the that's
not that farfetched from people that's
not you you used a maryn Monroe poster
on the wall I'm saying let's start with
Kanye growing up a middle class area in
Chicago so that's different than bone
and Bone and Cleveland Brother Lynch and
sa them them people are from Place
houses was $13 for sure right so that's
different houses might have been $13 in
Chicago the houses is $13 in Cleveland
right you can get a house in Cleveland
right now for about 7,000 let me know
where duplex I got you I got you where
bone grew up at yeah shout out to to uh
the Cavaliers so so what my point I'm
saying to you is I'm not I haven't came
to a great conclusion it's Kanye West so
it's hard to challenge that type of
Legacy but if you think about it but if
you think about it right his first song
is about a car crash where he had
insurance but what got everybody is the
[__] black music he sampled in Shaka
Khan MH that carries the story Kanye is
the best at using black music and
finding a place where he meets black
people at remember hip hop is almost
like you think Kanye makes he's a black
artist yes but but when you say black
right it's it's it's as simple as he's a
black man making music right but he's
not the first artist to sample black
artists no no but he's he's fantastic at
it yeah when I'm tell you what he does
with that Shaka Khan and but if you
listen to a lot of his songs even the
depth of his struggle is very Eddie
winow but you know what it was what was
dope about Kanye is that his struggle
was relat to white people to a lot of
people to mainstream America cuz if you
could talk about how you hated working
at the mall at the Gap that's like
main no okay but but but like imagine if
snoop's first album is about him talking
about having a problem working at the
mall but that's what made Kanye
different was he was a [__] pop
artist you could relate to him versus
you couldn't relate to none of these he
not a pop artist he was making some
backpack dope rap [__] but he was
talking about not backpack to work at
the mall because this is the the
minority of the of
everybody aren't in gangs and aren't
involved in street life and not but then
whether or not they grew up around it
would you would you at least say that
most people period no matter what the
race of them or or where they're from
are not tied up in street life are
civilians is that fair most they're not
from the ghetto okay people from the
ghetto have normal jobs at the mall no
they don't have them at the mall but
they do have normal jobs are you trying
to tell me people from the ghetto don't
work at the mall yes but that's not
that's a wild thing to say that's a very
wild blanket statement you're pushing it
further right let's what I'm saying is
Kan most of us work Kanye made an made
music for the normal person that's what
pop music is no pop music listen this is
what you got to understand is that not
what pop music is cuz for the everyday
person no but you're trying to ex you're
you're essentially trying to say well
Kanye was making music for uh privileged
people who had normal jobs I did not
first off yes it's not you're not
privileged if you have a normal job that
makes you mainstream American but even
people let's say from where you're from
right but that but but even in now
you're talking about I'm asking you so
people from where you're from right your
let's say your neighborhood what
percentage of them are actively
throughout their life
practicing involvement in let's say
Street culture illegal activity gangs we
all talk the same way so that's I'm not
talking about talk I'm talking about I'm
talking about how you get your money the
lifestyle you live you can't pick the
part of a culture you enjoy right cuz de
soul is culture right but it don't mean
that it don't mean there's probably
people from your area down who had to
get up and go to work and do their
normal job I got homies that got jobs
that Kanye [__] and was like yo this
dude's talking about working a a [__]
overtime shift at a retail store this is
am [__] pop music no it's not that's
normal middle class [__] that's what pop
America is so you're trying to say Kanye
wasn't making hip-hop that's not what
I'm saying I have I told you I've been
having this dilemma in my mind to say
that so so you make a lot of blanket
statements then no I'm I'm giving you
really consistent statements consistent
considering all of your statements
according to your logic Kanye is not
hipop I'm thinking about it I've been
I've been on this plug cuz I've been
saying for years he's hip-hop but then I
think about it I'm like that's why black
America is disconnected from him right
now they like well I think they also
might be disconnected cuz he said some
wild [__] no he did he said the same
[__] he been saying since the first day
and he has been wrapped up in a very
unrelatable
culture whether it's the Kardashians
whether it's you know why huh cuz he
ain't that type of guy but he was that
type of guy no he wasn't he was just
doing it over Shaka Khan and the other
thing well okay that's
my that's what I'm starting to believe I
was like he always been this crazy [__]
Kanye is like so so do you think Playboy
card's hip-hop no okay I got to ask but
he got some dope [__] the first one but
all that weird devil [__] I had to slap
little cuz like all that ho ass [__]
they doing with the devil that'll be cuz
be I don't like that yeah I know you do
I hate that you you some little Nas X
though no no little Nas is cool cuz he
just fake gay I told you you g to see
one day it's going to come out cuz fake
gay what does that mean he's playing for
the money so you don't think little no
no I don't believe cuz is gay I believe
they paying cuz and he know his play and
he running his play why would you not
it's [__] who doing a gangster rap
it's [__] who do it act they fake D
boys why would you not be fake gay for
money especially if you young why hasn't
more people been fake gay for money then
they it has been people fake gay for
money fake gay yeah lot of fake F fake
the gayness easy you act gay for people
like a fake gangster rapper like a [__]
who act like he a gangsta but he's not I
think there's probably more fake
straight people people than fake gay
people I would agree yeah I would agree
for I for sure would agree but that
don't mean Lil N X is not straight I
think l n x is uh is gay I don't believe
that and I think it's he's gay facing
you think he's gay I know we talked
about this last time but I I just don't
know if that's a that's I don't know if
that's the uh that's that's what my
that's what my way if he really wanted
to like lean into something he would
have just been the country artist he
couldn't you know that's not going to
work no white folks ain't [__] with
that negro they did when Oldtown Road
they
didn't I don't know money man where's he
from born money man money man you listen
I don't I haven't I haven't so listen so
first off I can't talk about Travis
Scott but I think Travis Scott has
defined his sound but I think he defines
his sound as uh what is like Rave or uh
what's that ra rage no he's making
hip-hop but he's defined his music Uzi
defines his music as rock and roll I
think Uzi defines himself as a rock star
yeah that makes rock music no he doesn't
make rock music yes but again this is my
point see see how you see how you laying
claim to that see how you won't let
[__] be nothing else but rappers cuz
they Sno dogs a rockar yeah but but no
he's not what do you mean he's not he's
Snoop Dog he's in the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame he's in every Hall of Fame yes
cuz he's Hall of f he's a hipop star
he's a rock star he's a pop star he is
the guy yeah but but let me make my
point before we get lost listen I I
haven't studied none of those other guys
so I can't comment per on yachty cuz I
don't know yachty story I don't know tra
story I don't know them but I don't
think they Define themselves and I think
they will maybe y would be the closest
person that could consider himself
hip-hop or would well his dad was a big
photographer he did photos for dead
press TI uh but he didn't grow up like
like from what I understand he grew up
like with you know like a middle class
kid yeah and I'm not saying I don't I
don't know I had to really study before
I say that tra I think he defines his
music as something else and I think Uzi
defines his music and his existence L at
something else but I think because they
use rap immediately everybody classifies
somebody black in rapping as hip hop and
it's [__] [__] up if Uzi Uzi as
black people created rock and roll right
he can go in and Define it as he want
that's his claim to rights you can't
look at Nirvana or no YouTu and then say
he got to make music like that we did it
the first time so we could redefine it
the second time okay it's fair of him to
do that but what I'm saying
is back to the point we were saying in
my neighborhood being in in Street urban
life is not necessarily you know being a
criminal like there's a lot of people
like LL wasn't a criminal there's people
who grew up in the same culture well
what I'm saying though is that there are
people who aren't criminals who maybe
they're they're gravitating they
gravitated towards College Dropout
because oh this is something different
I'm not disag this is this is actually I
liked it as a criminal but that's not
the point I like Michael Jack I like I
like a pop artist but I'm saying like if
I like to me as somebody who was wearing
the best by when I was 16 I was like oh
[__] I get it this [__] is
rapping about working at a shitty retail
job you do get it that's my point I'm
saying so what I'm saying is but I grew
up I didn't grew up middle class I grew
up poor as [__] I know you did cuz Fenix
got some [__] crazy sick ass poor
places yeah they do yeah sick that
nobody talks about sick some crazy [__]
shout out to Fenix cuz they go through
some [__] nobody talks about it true but
the point I'm saying to you is when we
saying this it's like
everybody that grow up with us talk the
same way everybody who grows up with us
eats the same way every everybody that's
not but that's not Universal that's
where you're at right but but that's all
Street Urban culture it's the way the
because people in Atlanta are different
people in Gary Indiana are different
every ghetto people in Cleveland are
different every ghetto there is no
middle class culture there only
tradition in middle class and in wealth
there is no culture so therefore how
could you have hip-hop somewhere where
there's no culture so if Drake let's say
Drake for example shout out to D you
think the Beasty Boys are are hip-hop no
they punk rock that made a hip-hop album
okay do you think Licensed to Ill is
hip-hop yes they made a hip-hop album
okay so that's hip-hop I agree because
but they actually punk rock they started
as punk rockers punk rock and Hip-Hop
right are Step Brothers okay Run DMC a
what they're hip-hop listen correct they
of course do you do you do you think
that Run
DMC like obviously Run DMC is kind of
looked at as like the first like I would
would you say like pop hip hop group in
terms of like their popularity in terms
of popularity when we use the word yeah
yeah I guess to some degree
um would you discount them working with
AOS Smith because no I don't think I
think you can work with whoever you want
to but I think Hip Hop is more as much
as Street Urban culture is defined
through crime and and densely populated
crime rid neighborhoods it don't mean
everyone's a criminal I didn't say I
didn't say that was the case which was
my point not everyone's a criminal so
feel like you were pretty much saying
nah where we're from this is what we we
we don't [__] with regular Mall jobs no
that we we're we're denied Mall jobs
that's not true yes have you been in the
mall yes I've been in the mall in the
worst areas yes yes yes I got some of
the my worst type of friends working at
the mall steal it out of the back of a
foot I'm not saying that right allegedly
back in the day I'm saying the poverty
and the oppression here's a here's a
here's a here's a Richard conversation
but let me get that point off I'm saying
we're all the culture is created through
the crime the crime happening to
everybody whether you involved or not
you know what the crime that is to
education programs to where the
education programs are trash and you
don't speak great English so y'all make
up slang and y'all all talk the same way
it don't matter if cuz got a job at the
mall in the hood or if he's selling dope
we all talk the same we all got the same
lingo we all do the same thing I this is
the this is what I likened it to and
this going to be crazy cuz you know
you're a white man in this conversation
is funny you're a niggaer but you're a
white man the point I'm saying to you is
there's always been three black cultures
in America right or three the ideas of
three identities there's a slave you
know American slave culture right that's
where you get sold F that's where you
get all that there's a freed men since
the first day black people been on this
planet especially in this country
there's been freed black people and then
there's been slave master it's a smaller
culture of black people it's not a
culture it's a tradition of life that
really small minut of black slavers
right that's there small freemen slaves
Kanye is a Freeman his whole
conversation is Freeman he has no no
idea what [__] from where we from are
talking about that's why you'll say
something like slavery is a choice Kanye
reminds me of a kid that got to visit
his cousins on the plantation it was
like we need to leave here once this
weekend when I go home y'all go with me
that makes sense that's how he talks cuz
his mind and that's what middle class
does to you it creates a place to where
the world is Limitless the world is not
like like your world is not real to them
it's the upside down right okay that's
fair that's what hip hop is but again
because people want to piece of it and
it's like it's something seems so cool
they want a piece of the lingo they want
a piece of the get down but they don't
want a piece of the consequence that's
why I'm really careful with who I say
and who I believe represents me as a
ghetto person from Hip Hop now if I
start allowing somebody like Drake
forgive me Drake again shout out to the
homies it's no disrespect but if you
don't speak not one thing on what's
going on with black people in this
country not one stance not one that's
been my biggest critique I don't even
care cuz he's Canadian right but I I
just I just feel like he doesn't ever
have an opinion on anything but except
now he's wearing rainbow Clips so you're
endorsing movements but you're not
endorsing the people that put you in
position to be where you at now yeah I I
do think it's like interesting that like
like why you don't have shade for no why
your shade is for Joe bu he he not first
off a rich Jewish man right bragging
about being rich to some niggaer that
come from the ghetto like Joe bus that
[__] is like cringy whereas like well I
just think I mean I said this on Twitter
the other day I said
uh I don't think Joe Buton said anything
that was unfair or disrespectful and I'm
not mad and I'm not mad at Drake being
offended at his critique of cuz Dr I'm a
little I'm a little mad at that cuz I
feel like Drake bro you have to
understand like people are going to have
an opinion about your music and as long
as they're not crossing the line or
they're not saying anything and he
should be able to have an opinion about
them but my thing is why does it go
right to what you have or money like
you're like Drake is actually a talent
talented accomplished MC record making
[__] monster yeah why go to money I
have a private jet and you have to take
first class flights because you're a
rich Jewish man right that's like being
a broke black person it's like that's
how common to to to the main ears that
sounds it's like you going to talk about
a [__] being broke it wasn't yeah it
wasn't necessary for sure
so I'm not mad at him but he could have
talked about so many things you know
what I mean and that's what hip hop is
it's bearing the burden of Street Urban
culture you have to represent right see
when you don't have when you don't have
to represent nobody Jay could have never
went out like that because he
represented Mars in Brooklyn he had to
that's the only way he could Garner
support Snoop could never you you know
another reason why Snoop is such a
fantastic hip-hop artist he will never
break crippin he defines crippin how he
wants that's what cripping is all about
you know what I'm saying long as you
don't break them that one rule about no
snitches you can do with cripping as you
please just don't make nobody look dumb
and Snoop has done a great job of not
making people look stupid and he never
broke away when you don't have to bear
the burden of culture when you don't got
to represent hip hop is all about
representing the people we talking about
do they [__] represent do do people
from their Community feel like this is
our spokesman like when I talk rest
assured any real [__] from Watts most
[__] from WTS going be like that [__]
is all right [__] from La going to be
like glasses is all right cuz I I have
to I can't do no sucker [__] how I'mma
show my face in the 60s how I'mma show
my face in a trades how I'mma show my
faces in the great streets how I'mma
show my face in East coasts if I go
looking dumb I have the burden of
representing ghettos that's what hip-hop
is LL had the responsibility LL and Nas
had to represent Queens 50 had to
represent Southside Queens Jay had to
represent Brooklyn if you don't got to
represent [__] and you can still be
successful [__] you are not one of us
if you can embarrass us every week you
don't think that Drake represents
Toronto no all right not the streets I
mean he represents Toronto as the
Raptors represent Toronto and he's their
guy like I think Drake my problem is
Drake represent black people right and
we be looking like cuz what are you
doing you know what I mean like what the
[__] cuz why would you do that but the
problem is when we try try to hold him
with our ghetto respons he's not a
ghetto kid he don't come from the ghetto
he don't if you got to think morale and
Street Life create standards create
morals you know I mean the religion
excuse me and Street Life create morals
without it America is just like a dog
eat dog place right they [__]
up yeah I think we can at times be
unfair towards Drake because he is such
a just massive shining star in in
hip-hop I think that at times Drake does
things where I'm like okay you're like
being a little too emotional towards Jo
but and like to Discount him as like a
failed rapper unfair I I don't I don't I
don't really care about that I I do
think though I I care about is some
[__] hair clips see I don't I don't
care yeah if you go to Door why don't
you like the hair clips because why are
you doing Snoop Dog had had had a lot of
[__] going on with his hair and showed
the sugarfree yeah but they ain't
putting rainbow hair clips that's a
purpose he's doing a lot of things on
purpose to do certain things and I'm
asking you why you ain't stood up for no
[__] if you going to stand up for
somebody who you going to represent you
who's he representing you think he's
representing the the AL boys you know he
is and that's his thought I don't think
so then why would you put rainbow hair
clips in your head why does Rainbow got
to be exclusive to something that that
it it ain't a God it's just what if he
bought a pack of hair clips and they
came in multiple colors why does
everything have to have a specific
meaning or agenda attached to it Drake's
hair clips don't mean anything except
for their hair clips you really believe
that do you think Drake purposely said
nah give me the rainbow pack yes no
crazy you don't believe Dr Drake is like
one of the greatest Minds like Kanye
inop let me tell you something not see
the problem is is let me just say this
the problem
is certain like in 2023 for whatever
reason we always have to put a meaning
or stick some sort of agenda to
something that it don't don't got
nothing to do with because we all know
it means something it doesn't it does
it's just hair clips no it doesn't it's
not are you serious it's not if I were
so you do you think Drake's hair clips
are him endorsing a certain lifestyle
yes really yes and it's the mainstream
thing to do what does that mean that's
the thing to do at a mainst level across
the world that's what every pop artist
would be doing across the world that
every people not this not by accident
you think this [__] by this [__] is
brilliant like Drake is so what is
Drake's agenda with his colorful hairc
now we going to go into some details but
obviously what is your uh perceived
obviously endorsing right which I don't
care about that but my thing is the
[__] who made you famous These [__]
In America these ghettos cuz we pushed
cuz like he couldn't just be a pop star
and be that we push CS the ghettos push
CS we said the females the black women
from the ghettos push C you ain't said
nothing about nothing happening to these
Sisters You Ain't posting nothing that's
happening to these sister you not saying
nothing about no [__] and I got let
that go cuz you was Canadian I'm like
you know what he don't have to give [__]
what happened to American [__] I don't
disagree with you sure on that point
because I do think at at certain points
in time it'd be nice if we knew what
Drake thought about I don't know George
Floyd or ban Taylor which I'm not even
asking that cuz most pop artist or or or
you know he lives here a lot like
there's a lot of turmoil going on with
our political system just any sort of
opinion and I'm okay with that but like
you said he's Canadian yes what do you
think about Justin Trudeau Drake facts
facts facts what do you think about the
Canadian truck drivers who I'm not mad
because that's a hip-hop responsibility
okay okay but so I think that's separate
than you thinking that there's an agenda
with his hair clips you missing a point
of somebody that's so brilliant to know
not to speak on something he's so this
[__] him and 40 are some of the best
scientists I ever seen in the music
business like when it comes to creating
records marketing and understand how to
Market Dr like Michael Jordan right like
Michael Jordan purposely has said
Republicans and Democrats by both my
sneakers why would I take a stance on
any of this publicly cuz then I I kind
of and Drake's kind of the same kind of
guy yeah but but Drake Drake appeals to
everybody and I don't think he wants to
[__] that up and and I'm not mad at that
but my thing is right that's why you
know who else does that pop stars yeah I
mean there's also artists there's no
hip-hop artists that do that we won't
even let them go we won't even Nick if
you try that if you try that and you
represent us it's a problem what you not
going to speak up Thug say something
like oh we ain't talking about that [__]
we talking about young [__] they was
asking Thug about the boy that got
killed Mike uh in Ohio what's brother
yeah yeah yeah uh Mike uh Michael Mike
Brown Michael Brown Brown Michael Brown
and it was like yeah you know he was on
the red carpet like you know how you
feel about Mike Brown like oh man we
ain't tripping off that old politics
[__] we out here getting [__] fell
apart oh my God you [__] and this
[__] is a [__] who do drugs he I don't
even think we should even really want
his opinion cuz he go through so much
[__] and be high you know yeah yeah
you're not going to look to Thug for
political views but he still has to cuz
guess why he is from the ghetto in
Atlanta and we like you better talk you
better speak for us and that's the
responsibility of hip-hop I don't give a
[__] if it's tribe de Soul anybody you
are responsible for speaking for us in
Hip
Hop okay so and if you don't we look at
you funny but the only people we don't
worry about is people that ain't hip-hop
what's the issue with uh with the hair
clips nothing I have no issues with it
I'm saying this is I'm asking you this
is the first so you are officially your
stance is he's purposely from the nails
the hair he's going to keep going okay
so do you think Andre 3000 was doing
that in '96 997 when when when he was
wearing
certain I just think he got Erica a Badu
[__] and that [__] is some [__] okay
Drake ain't got no ER what about Thug
when Thug wore dress on his album cover
yeah I think Thug is from Atlanta where
the street Urban culture is tied into
homosexuality that for some reason
nobody in Atlanta talks about it's like
right there like I've never seen a
bigger demographic of gay black folks in
the ghetto like Atlanta never seen that
do you think it's possible Drake just
got a bag of hair clips no zero chance
okay he's too smart he too smart to just
do something and don't have no idea what
he impossible it's it's impossible 0% 0%
0% 0% a half a percent chance he just
put some hair clips in his hair and they
happen to be different colors no zero
chance what zero
chance he's Drake Drake is brilliant dog
there's a confusion Drake is [__]
brilliant dog him and 40 together dog
them [__] could put [__] together the
[__] E 40 or 40 the producer 40 the
producer like he could come with [__]
bro they could put [__] together like
some of the [__] they be doing music i'
be like [__] like you know what I mean
cuz you got to catch up to this [__] and
it's like [__] like this is how smart
they are he's a marketing [__]
machine you know what I mean he knows
well I think that you're rear reaching I
understand why you feel that way cuz it
would actually mean you would have to be
accountable for decisions you make no I
just and we love a world where we could
just make people unable think but in Hip
Hop we have to be accountable I just
think not everything famous people does
has an agenda attached to it I know
because you which it don't make sense
because you would think that some of
these people are some of the greatest
marketing Minds ever and you would think
that they would accidentally do
something even though they've been
controlling the narrative for 20 years
okay Switching subjects shout out to
Drake yeah shout out to Jersey